[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the break room everybody
Our Daily Show that keeps you updated on
all the nerdy news you need to know
um today we've got some really fun stuff
to discuss Guardians in the DCU what
Star Destroyers on Coruscant what and
then you got to stick around the end of
this show
is gonna turn musical oh it's going to
Pivot in a way you don't expect wow and
it's really really fun I guarantee uh
with me uh for that Journey I've got
Brandon Barrick Jessica Clements and
Tommy bechtold
I'm Tech Huddleston we're thrilled to
have you here today let's jump right
into it we've got we've got Mando in the
thumbnail damn it let's get some man
doing this whoa and speaking of going
commando wow I am feeling pretty free
today whoa okay let's just say these
denim will be burned all right in the
new trailer for season three of the
Mandalorian we got a glimpse of the
struggle between the Mandalorian people
the factions they're all split out like
shooting stars shooting stars with flame
throwers you know whistling birdies that
fly out of their wrist because season
three is going to delve deeper into the
lore of the fall of Mandalore say that
three times fast
yeah
Jessica you asked her you literally said
it Jessica great you just let me finish
thank you and did John's quest to
rebuild the plan we plan it for its
people we also know there will likely be
some infighting between the groups of
mandalorians vying for power and since
the Mandalorian is not a slow burn like
uh it was not a slow burn Star Wars show
with political infighting like Andor or
even like a Game of Thrones Style Show
rather it's an action-packed eight
episode per season action drama you guys
get ready I'm ready we're going on we're
going on trips to the outer rim to pick
up a converter for a vehicle so that we
can have groco eat a frog again that's
coming guys oh baby there's High
likelihood that these mandalorians are
going to get into a civil Warrior well I
hope I don't have to intervene on that
because I can't stop two more Nations
for fighting we want to talk about the
ramification I'm talking to you Kim Jong
cut it out I ain't going over there
again I brought my improv troop and you
booed us
now we we want to talk about the
ramifications of all this fighting and
everything that could play out okay so
here's some questions I got for you guys
okay we know that Boca tan Wants to Rule
Mandalore Boba Fett has also expressed
his disinterest in returning the
Mandalore stating the Empire reduced
into glass during the patch now that
wasn't a very good Bob effect that was
pretty good man all right we've also got
Paz visla on the armorer with their
group which is called John what's it
called again
the tribe the tribe
the tribe
all right so these are the people in the
sewers that we met yes it's you know
they're they're burning all the the best
bars best deals yeah and as far as we
know they are the most uh zealous they
are the most hardcore of the religious
Fanatics like I said they're the ones
who shot the lights off and locked the
door on Halloween so we have a strict by
the booked sect trying to grab power in
Mandalore we've got Bo uh bocaton sorry
and then we've you know we've also got
uh all these other random tribes out
there who do we think is gonna like you
know who's gonna get the power who's
gonna end up on top at the end and we've
talked about like uh and Eric was did a
breakdown of the trailer that's out on
the channel now you did a great job with
that like there's some interesting
things in that trailer and one
interesting thing I noticed that's not
in the trailer in the trailer we never
see any Mandalorian on Mandalorian
violence right yeah we're assuming it's
gonna happen and we see like
mandalorians shooting stuff and grabbing
stuff and doing whatever but you can
never see who they're doing it too in
the frame right it's interesting though
because we've been misdirected before
because bogaton got a hold of the
darksaber before she raised it up all
the mandalorians some with helmets on
some with helmets on if this is are off
the in the anime series they bowed they
went like this and then like half of
them were like we don't respect her she
didn't win it in combat yeah so it's
like they're I mean like it's you
Brandon made a good example of like it's
religions and and and you know there's
it's there can be one Central religion
in all of these offshoots and they just
constantly bicker with each other about
which is the one true version of that
religion it's like you could never get
them to all agree on anything so it's
like it seems like the darksaber is the
one thing that could get them all to
unite but it has to be won through
combat right like you have to basically
kill the previous owner you have to kill
them is it like
I I don't know the rules like can you
disarm not because we my Gideon did not
die no yeah and also I I want to point
out another thing we don't see in the
trailer is MAF Gideon even though
um he Giancarlo Esposito is listed as
being in this season well he's done all
the Press he's been in every convention
you see the doctor uh yes Dr Pershing Dr
Pershing looks like he's on corsicon or
another person or or the planet that
there's the the capital planet that
Kenobi was right it could be that looks
like Tokyo yeah yeah
uh my thing is one the Mandalorian
didn't jarring yeah it doesn't seem like
he wants to be a mandal I don't think so
either he's kind of like Boba Fett we're
both fats like yeah I guess I have this
armor my dad gave it to me and it means
a lot to me but like I don't care about
like they're not they're not really a
part of the culture no no they're more
like yeah I dig the style I want to be a
badass like mandalorians like the armor
it's strong but I also think like it's
not necessarily that he doesn't want to
live like a Mandalorian it's that he
doesn't want to live with other
mandalorians he's fine he's a fair point
right he got raised in this cult he kind
of it clearly seems like he's like wow
well I I broke the rules of this call
and other than them rejecting me my life
has been you know okay I found this
little foundling that I'm training I
have all these new friends who are like
you know helpful and come to rescue
actually care about saving my life
whereas you know really only one time in
the entire show have we seen the uh I
can't God the tribe come to his rescue
at the very end of season one so it's
kind of I to me it's more like he wants
to redeem himself he wants to get right
he wants to get his Ledger back in the
black with the mandalorians and then
just get out and start you know cruising
around the outer rim saving people
hopefully getting cop Vance out of his
water respirator and interesting I like
that as an idea of like because we do
see it looks like he's kind of maybe a
part of some peace talks or something
right some kind of big get-together when
when he's hanging out with grief karga
and there's battles going on looks like
he's in the middle of this but it
doesn't feel like that's where he wants
to be maybe he's just like I'm just
gonna be here until you guys work this
out and I want to hit the road and go be
a bounty hunter again yeah and it also I
mean not to keep bouncing around but
before we go move on from this
I let's all just put our bets on our
horses who at the end of this show at
the end of season three is going to be
in Char is going to be the leader of the
mandalorians and I guess there's an
option that no one will be I don't think
it'll be Den jarin right I don't think
it should be him okay uh it's a big
pivot for the show if it's if it's now
about leading a planet or something yeah
which is what they do with book of Boba
Fett like it's not about him being a
bounty hunter it's about him running a
planet now and uh maybe a crime said to
get I don't know uh I would say Boca
time yeah yeah
it really wants to be in charge of it
she got to show your face to me if
you're gonna lead a piano right yeah
yeah so I don't need the the armor being
in charge she's two fundamentalists
see I disagree I think my money is on
the armorer at the end we know that
there there's a I mean and I say this
more from a practical usage point we
know from some footage from from
celebration the armor is going to be
seen fighting the armor is going to be
much more involved in this in the season
I have a feeling she could maybe not
necessarily as like a good outcome maybe
it's not a a certainly a benevolent
outcome she could seize the Mandalorian
throne and the darksaber and and and be
the leader I like that because like we
don't really have a big bad heading into
this MAF Kitty has kind of been neutered
yeah right like we're in between evil
Empires at this point in Star Wars right
so like how great if the big bad the the
ultimate antagonist comes from within
the mandalorians right and kind of like
since they're not necessarily fighting
against an Empire at this point they're
fighting against each other that's kind
of a Star Wars story we haven't seen
yeah uh in live action at least right
Jessica who do you think I agree I think
it's just because you're wearing a
headband I think I think that the
biggest big bad on this show are the
creators of this show who constantly put
grogu in danger and we're we at home
have to like be worried about him
constantly being killed or squished or
stolen right or something annoying like
yeah and it's like oh and and they force
him to relive his trauma yeah yeah it's
like hidden just like stop setting him
down
being like okay you sit right here it
looks I gotta go fight him it looks like
and we might talk about this in a minute
we're gonna take a journey back to maybe
his Darkest Hour uh whatever that origin
story it also does seem like he's
getting uh powered up this like like
Roku is getting a power upgrade he's
also getting a bassinet upgrade they
went from whatever the like you know uh
generic Amazon Prime ordered no offense
if they're a sponsor uh they're not you
know the Amazon brand one that you can
get like a phone charger that'll die in
two days to like the what Swiss or
Norwegian German manufacturing baby
bassinet that's like we guarantee your
baby will live to be 150 if you just
keep them in this basket like a Volvo do
you think pelimoto hooked him up with
that better she's like she's like I I
all of the uh children that I've had all
over tattooing with my various daily and
says I've put them in the same bassinets
but it's all you can see it's more
heavily armed it comes with a little
headlight in the front Eric Voss pointed
that out in his video cute little one
headlights that's good for kids so he's
constantly knocking people in the arm
for one headlight out but yeah I think
that grogu maybe we're gonna get in this
season grogu can take care of himself
much more to kind of assuage that
because the show is called the
Mandalorian yeah and obviously they
struck gold with little baby Yoda and
like that has become the central point
of the show and it should and three
seasons of that is great but I would
love at the end of this show if it is
more we go back to DIN jarin and what is
his whole purpose is it just getting
grogu to the point where he can fulfill
his Destiny is he meant to is grogu
meant to leave the mandalorians as a
Jedi for sensitive Mandalorian hybrid
when is he gonna start getting a funny
little voice like Yoda do they give him
a tiny helmet yeah
you make a great point that the name of
the show is the Mandalorian uh how did
they not for season two or three uh
write that up on uh a whiteboard and
then write a money symbol after it
mandalorians
all right so just staying on
mandalorians for a little bit longer we
do get the wide shot of Mandalore we see
this the city the capital city and ruins
that was uh once under a dome there it
is you see it right there there's a
beautiful image of it thank you John uh
uh and that the armorer describes the
destruction of that it's like Tie
fighters the Empire just came in and
bombed the hell out of it sure so it's
that seems to me like not a great place
to live now I've lived in some pretty
bad Apartments but I don't know that I
would find real estate there however if
you look junkie put that image back up
again I don't know if we go wide enough
yeah if you look just to the left of it
it's green yeah things are living there
seemingly from The Living Waters
underground that go around of Mandalore
so something presumably besides grass
survived there something or someone do
you think that whoever is there could be
mandalorians that went underground into
the caves and they might have a little
something to say about people coming
back to try and take their city like we
have that Christopher Lloyd character
that we don't know who he's playing okay
but they made a cast announcement put it
in variety and deadline so that usually
means that their role is significant
right
I know he could just he could be like
Reef cargo's interior designer and be
playing this thing or they get a I mean
Christopher Lloyd is in his 80s now they
get a body double to put a Mandalorian
here on any voices or characters Nick
Nolte season one right he got to be uh a
voice actor for that little character
right yeah I have spoken uh yes so I
mean do we think
Christopher Lloyd could be hiding out in
those little caves it's like a man the
leader of the surviving mandalorians is
that or or is there somewhere else that
you could think from watching the first
two seasons of the show
Christopher Lloyd fits better in it
would be interesting to have Christopher
Lloyd's on the like more villainous
signs yeah if he's who Dr person's going
to see or whatever like he's somehow
involved in the Empire kind of like in
the Werner Herzog mode in season one
yeah we saw like and or two the man
who's like running the ISB like yeah
older figureheads iron like maybe he's
like a trusted confidante of the emperor
he's like I gotta I'm working on this
whole clone project uh something like
that because it would be a champion of
Christopher Lloyd as just a voice or
like under a helmet or something like
that's no fun I mean no intents and
purposes we have Pedro pascals I mean
and for the first season yeah it's just
a voice and then in the second season
they're like we gotta whip that helmet
off we gotta take that we got to go pop
that top off sweetheart show me what
you're working with the Marvel router of
any time there's a break in the fight
let's take our helmets off real fast I
will say one more thing with Christopher
Lloyd uh Star Wars has a history of
using some celebrity voices for Droids
yeah
[Music]
I can't fly this thing oh bloody This
ship's going too fast
oh Marty
okay let's see a meme Droid yes he's
meme he's mean he's that he's the M3 M3
Droid
all right we kind of already covered
this Boca Chan section so let's just
turn this on through oh
thank you for your Super Chat hey guys I
feel like Disney needs to keep the grogu
toy sales up so we can see a girl who
wearing a Mandalorian helmet at some
point there it is a season yeah
xenix uh um I see here are you from the
UK you're getting
um d23 in England this year sorry Star
Wars celebration yeah even more
appropriate and will we have a presence
there and will the presence be my
presence fingers crossed come on send me
back to jelly old London last time I was
there the city went no thank you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I think Giancarlo has a big role that
they're hiding like young Leia and
Kenobi can't wait for Mando season three
and hope to get Christopher Lloyd as oh
yeah I think mace is going to be the one
that saved grogu we're gonna get a d
aged Samuel L I was gonna say Lewis uh
hold on to your hat I don't want to ever
tease this but if you like that theory
or if that's something you feel you may
enjoy a little video I'm gonna lay down
on wax tonight uh hopefully it'll be on
our Channel by Friday right Friday
release I'm gonna talk all about who
could be saving little grogu from that
Temple oh well you gotta watch the
videos
I'm not telling these soups
uh we're gonna come back and uh again if
you have any other
um big thoughts on oh thank you uh Zach
strong name in the Super Chat love y'all
do you uh do we think we will see how
grogu escapes
big Friday video just come check out the
big Friday video You're Gonna Love
all the little theories that I have what
I've done today has gone completely
whack Bonk whack box I know who saves
Grogan it's jar jar thanks uh what would
that sound like it's a miss a safe girl
Google and he shoots his tongue out uh
but instead of hitting Goku it hits all
the other Jedi and kills all the other
Jets oh and he's like
yeah I've built an empowering a stirring
inside me
we're gonna come back and and again if
you have more kind of thoughts
predictions hot takes on middle ores and
Mandalorian season three put them in the
chat yeah try to come back to the other
show but real quick we want to um shout
out the folks helping us bring uh the
break room to you all week long our
friends at nordvpn we're doing a special
thing this week uh we're doing a movie
club on Friday okay where we're going to
be talking about uh the Cinematic
treasure Knives Out uh the first that's
a soft k
yeah I've been saying connives out well
you could say however you like Tommy
um we're gonna be talking about Good
Knives Out uh the first uh Benoit uh
blank uh film are we pronouncing all the
consonants
um
but
Knives Out not currently streaming for
free anywhere in the U.S it is streaming
on Japanese Netflix so we're gonna use
nordvpn uh to stream Japanese nor uh
Netflix normally
um you know uh streaming services like
Netflix they geo-restrict content so
they have a different library in the US
the UK France Japan South Korea wherever
but with nordvpn you can hide where
you're from and trick Netflix into
thinking we currently live in Japan so
you can watch a totally different
library of Netflix flicks can you watch
it in English yes great point we were
just talking about that yesterday it
doesn't mean you have to watch a movie
in Japanese but that would also be a
very fun movie club if we were like
I loved Jamie Lee Curtis's performance
had no idea what she was saying the
entire time nope you could watch in
English no matter what country you log
in you can watch it in Lost in
Translation and then the whole movie
will be in Japanese even the Japanese
parts and it'll be fun you can just
watch it all as it was meant to be seen
can't confirm uh whether a loss in
Translation is available on Japanese
Netflix but we'll find out uh again
that's one of the main benefits of
nordvpn the one we're excited about here
this week but of course there's lots of
other benefits you get to hide uh from
your ISP you know what kind of websites
you're going to I will say people I know
sometimes download content illegally
content they have not paid for their
names I will not uh and a VPN can be
helpful for that interesting uh I would
just say I've heard rumors about that as
a member of several unions
you would never endorse that Zach
there's tons that nordvpn does it's not
just about like changing where you where
you're geolocated they also like block
malware they block pop-ups yes all sorts
of great stuff like that it makes
surfing the web a little bit safer if
you surf the way I do down with the
dirty sharks yeah it ain't how it
doesn't it doesn't hurt and you can put
it on like up to six devices yeah your
computer your smart TV yeah your phone
everything's connected yes so join us
watch knives out yourself so you can uh
join and be a part of the conversation
on Friday get in on the action get
nordvpn uh exclusive nordvpn at
nordvpn.com break room you get a huge
discount of your nordvpn plan plus a
bonus gift it's completely risk-free
with nord's 30-day money-back guarantee
that's n o r d v p n.com slash break
room we thank them uh for sponsoring the
show and uh we hope you'll check out
their awesome service now let's get to
some
headlines yes headlines yes uh an image
from the Disney plus trailer for
Mandalorian shows a star destroyer on
Coruscant there it is uh that image was
not in the trailer posted to YouTube now
Tommy as our resident Star Wars Star
Wars historian uh expert Wikileaks
co-host why is this significant well I'm
wondering if these are Star Destroyers
being rebuilt yeah
or are they being decommissioned or are
they being turned into luxury space
casinos well
I'm gonna kind of talk about my ass a
little bit trying to remember my history
but those Star Destroyers at the angle
at the top is not the more modern like
first ordinary thing they started doing
yeah I mean that weird little like
angular stuff I might be wrong well no
it does I mean the first order had the
weird like they also had like almost
like emblems on the top of them that had
like the kind of like
I I would I would take it to be that
these are either being yeah
decommissioned or like
upgraded for the first time because the
timeline is Mandalorian is taking place
while the first order is kind of rising
yeah
it's closer to Return of the Jedi yeah
it's what is it supposed to be nine BBY
so Return of the Jedi is kind of like
the prime gate right and then so this is
nine years after that and then the first
order is 21 years after that or
something along those lines I think
because that or no maybe I don't know I
get confused by this maybe or maybe it's
bb21 BBY fact calling if you know the
point being the first order
presumably the the the seeds of the
first order are already sprouted at this
point I just have not fully blossomed
anything this could be all of this could
be a grand conspiracy to like kind of
re-engage the first order which I mean
yeah I know we all we all uh get
uncomfortable talking about the sequels
and you know whether or not those were
ridiculous or we love them or somewhere
in the middle but like eventually if
these do tie into the movies in our in
our Canon we've got to start seeing why
the how the first order how people had
defeated the Empire and all of that good
will how it so quickly dissipated and
people were ready to put be put right
back under the thumb and join up with
the first order to be like because they
have I mean those those were not uh
poorly manned crafts they need a lot of
people for us awakens I mean we learned
more by the rise of Skywalker but by the
time before it's awakens comes around
there's thousands and thousands and
thousands and millions of people working
for the first order so all these people
that were like we're free this is over
we're like not actually reporting right
back to work make the uniform even more
naughtier people they showed a few
planets celebrating at the end to return
the gym let's try all of them there's a
lot of planets out there most of the
planets were like no a lot of those
planets are like I just want the trains
to run on time I don't care whose boot
I'm under I know I'm hearing that a lot
of those celebrations were staged I
don't know in my opinion it's the Jedi
who are bad that's true you have always
said uh some other uh Mandalorian season
3 News came out uh we got the directors
for season three were announced uh and
there's something returning directors
including uh Rick Fama YULA uh and then
Carl Weathers cargo Apollo Creed himself
will be directing an episode uh Bryce
Dallas Howard is coming back to direct
uh some and then some newcomers uh lee
Isaac Chung who directed a great movie
last year in 2021 uh manari which is an
interesting pivot that was kind of like
a a nice family drama and so this would
be fun to see him uh in the Star Wars
Universe Peter Ramsey who's one of the
filmmakers behind into the spider-verse
and then Rachel Morrison who's the
director of photography for black
panther excellent so it's a fun mix of
new folks that we want to see you know
stretching Carl Weathers also directed
an episode last season which was the I I
believe the crazy episode where they
found all the Clones all the cloned like
um Snokes yeah all this kind of like
kind of half half bread Snokes like half
like formed Snokes is it did they have a
stew going in that episode The Snokes do
they were like
that snoke seems ready you don't like
Arrested Development or you don't like
that okay yeah fair that was not a great
joke uh deadline is reporting that Nikki
M James Who's In A Book of Mormon uh has
joined the cast of Daredevil born again
this is interesting this is some of the
first casting Beyond Charlie Cox and
Vincent D'Onofrio that we've heard for
the series right uh details on her
character are currently unknown
um some other casting that we know
Michael Gandolfini James gandolfini's
son uh Margarita La Viva and Sandrine
Holt are also cast in it it's kind of a
new it's a very New York yeah kind of
cat I mean Mike Collins I think they're
going big and they're gonna make Mickey
and James Electra whoa
I think they're gonna say it ahead of
time I don't I am I'm not familiar with
recast not familiar with that actress uh
yeah she was in Book of Mormon she
originated the role uh the main like
female role I forget her name
um in in Book of Mormon and then like
she's directed or like she the other one
is she the girl that sings I I just
baptized her yeah yeah do we have an
asset John can we pull up what she looks
like
uh but she was also she's like done
other work on Broadway she's done she's
on like some TV shows but like again not
known for being like a film would you
buy her as a deadly ninja I thought it
was a deadly ninja I think anyone with
like Broadway Dance Training could
probably be yeah Electra watch out I'm
coming for you
it's electric okay yes exactly uh and
and were they left Elektra I mean
Elektra was dead in the Netflix series
right left in some some collapse Rubble
presumed Dead uh but it would be
interesting to like reintroduce this
character when she was born again born
again
oh nice work Tommy
um speaking of actresses you totally buy
us ask ass kickers I almost said ass
kissers that's very different uh Katie
O'Brien who's the actress in Ant-Man and
the watch condominia
um who's playing
a new
oh okay here here's the previous Nikki M
James oh okay yeah well we don't she's
not like flexing or anything in that so
we don't know we can assume that it acts
like sure body yeah I need to see it she
ripped
um but okay great Nikki M James
um well again we'll hopefully we'll find
out more as as we get closer to the
release of that series but pivoting to
Ant-Man the Lost quantumania yeah uh
Katie O'Brien will be playing gentura
who leads a group of freedom fighters in
the quantum realm we got a new image of
her oh
some um uh what was the sequel to pitch
black with Vin Diesel The Chronicles of
Riddick energy there I don't know
gentura I adore you give me some more uh
looks like Apocalypto a little bit oh
yeah yeah you think Gibson's got his
hands on this one oh boy Whoa I hope he
got his hands on an edit at least
I cut that movie
James Gunn teased the possibility of
bringing some of the cast of Guardians
of the Galaxy into the DCU in an
interview with Empire gun said the
Caster like my family I also know I will
work again with all those people
individually probably at my other job
wow does he work in a Sonic or something
are we sure that he leaves the DCU I've
been doing shifts at Best Buy and
honestly it's very free I mean this
leads we might need to talk about this
in a whole other episode like uh fan
casting the Guardians into DC roles yes
any that come to mind immediately well
the easiest way would be to flip
everybody right anyone who was a digital
or uh prosthetically enhanced character
yes make them a normal we got to see
live action Bradley Cooper Chris Pratt
blue and weird looking but like Dave
Batista just like a normal well he
doesn't look a normal man I mean a
normal Dave Batista yeah Bradley Cooper
probably is
not interested in being Hal Jordan but
he could be a new it seems like they
want to do John Stewart Green Lantern
which I don't blame them I think that's
a better game anyway but I uh if they
wanted to do a Hal Jordan Green Lantern
Bradley Coopers kind of got that I want
to see Chris Pratt as Zatanna oh uh
yeah
Chris Pratt plays a female's agenda oh I
think he yeah exactly yeah fishnet
stockings
does he transition just for the roles
Chris Pratt tucks into the role of
Zatanna
Vin Diesel as the Martian Manhunter oh
actually he would be kind of good in
that role uh he's got the voice for it
uh a couple of super chats we want to
shout out here I am saying do you think
din could meet tar vizla's Force ghost
at the Living Waters of Mandalore wow to
get his Redemption and learn how to
wield the darkness great Theory because
tarvisla is the Jedi Mandalorian kind of
hybrid that created the dark saber yeah
like a way back in the historic figure
for the and kind of like the the
um King Arthur of Mandalore right yeah
and mandalorians operate
quasi-similarly to Game of Thrones where
there's like houses house Vizsla
previously
he's obviously he's a descendant of
tarvin's yeah so we didn't see
tarvisland and be like I don't know who
the hell you are well he could identify
himself
and this is my ghost I don't know who
the hell you are our planet was
destroyed and all that most of the
history also yeah I'm seeing a ghost
what the hell this isn't a thing right
yeah you hear all that May the force be
with you [ __ ] I don't hey remember
that guy that couldn't smile that
rescued grogu it's a man whose face from
here up looked great his body from here
down look great but from right here to
here just made you feel a little
uncomfortable a little uncanny remember
how he was knocking people around with
his hands I'm a ghost that does it I
hope I hope that man
in the Living Water the healing water is
in there and all of a sudden this
Apparition appears and eraspberry voices
like ding ding give me your eggs give me
your eggs
suck your ass out of you and you will be
free
eggs very topical uh eggs are expensive
hard to find but in the jet how many
eggs you're going through in a week yeah
your consumption has changed is your
grocery store out of eggs this is the
produce I want you to identify in the
chat while you're going through how many
eggs how many eggplants how many bony
horses how many Christmas trees how many
beads how many beads how many peaches
how many peaches okay
uh Jamie Riley saying uh Star Wars for
life you think we'll see Ursa Wren or
sabine's brother in Mando season three
uh that's a great question I mean as we
expand out the the the the volume and
types of mandalorians we meet does
appear as though Quinn was asking about
like the night sisters as well like I
would like to see some more evil well
if we're going witches of dathomir
dothamir damathy or dothamir I gotta use
this consonants confuse me I do think
there is a chance
that this season has an old friend that
is associated with those witches
returning and once again I could tell
you but I'm gonna make you watch my
video oh I love this mirror
okay you do stuff it's time for
mandatory fun whoa no out of nowhere
you never know what mandatory fun will
strike
now
well talking with TV line
some musical elements for Agatha
Covenant of chaos saying who knows there
may be a little song here then but no
one is saying anything about that
sending at me bulk horn Kathy I know
there's gonna be more songs on this
because I hacked the cloud on Jack
shaffer's laptop whoa that's right
Hector cloud
she should have been using nordvpn and I
passed these yeah if you had a nordvpn
Shaffer you wouldn't have been exposed
but now everybody's got your song so we
have these are songs that are going to
be appearing in Covenant of chaos these
are Covenant kind of like of course one
of the big hit pop culture impacts of
One Division was the Agatha all along
and Kathy Hahn I call it Cath has said
oh that might be a ton of two or two I
don't know hadoopsy doopsy do there's
gonna be songs guys we got our mix on
them who's gonna sing this song first
let's bring over the mic well uh Jessica
I believe got her hands on two different
songs
again these are so these are songs that
are going to be in Covenant of chaos
that maybe are related to or revealing a
character right possibly yeah in the
same way that agates all along okay no
no no no no I got you I got you okay
um yeah I don't know who the song is for
oh okay but I'll try and sing I don't
even know who they're singing it to but
there's a name in it okay
um
how's the song
give me a second I got it I could make
you cookies John cookies John I get iron
suits and socks and thongs but even if
it took that long you never guess I'm a
witch never guess I'm a wish
guess I don't know my name soon as the
cameras fade call up the Scarlet Witch
and tell her she's the one to blame
tell me what your Witcher which the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
experience that was great beautiful song
A Little Bit Of Destruction who wants to
go next do you want me to do mine sure
okay well we have some Broadway actors
on this yeah Patti LuPone Patricia
LuPone Patricia I don't know if Aubry
Plaza's ever been on Broadway I don't
know I don't know you know what I hear
about Broadway with you here those neon
lights are bright
oh okay that's wrong I thought that was
going to go a different direction uh so
they're gonna do a little they're gonna
go full Broadway yeah uh on uh Agatha
cover the chaos and maybe do a cover of
a popular Broadway song okay maybe you
know it sing along sing along at home if
you do
do you hear the witches sing they're
performing spells again this is the
magic of some women who will not be
burned again when the flicking of your
hands matches the runes placed on the
walls tonight is the night that you will
burn my Fisto's balls
will you join in our coven who will be
dark and stand with me somewhere beyond
the dark oh the cold is there a spell
you wish to see then answer the call
that will give you the go to burn boys
do you hear the witches sing they are
killing other men this is the magic of
some women who will not be burnt again
when the magic from your hands creates a
fire in front of us all tonight is the
night that you will burn my face
wonderful well you you were on Broadway
I went just up the street oh okay Sesame
Street
I actually heard that there's a little
song about all the people of Westview oh
okay
and it goes a little something like this
you trapped all these people in your
neighborhood in your neighborhood in
your neighborhood saying you trapped all
these people in your neighborhood yeah
the people you kidnapped one day hey
Gotti the neighborhood busybody why
don't you tell us what you do each day
God he was a nosy Nancy she wore dresses
that were fancy then one day she sliced
her hand and the feeling was not Grand
but she still was under Wanda's spell oh
oh yes you trapped people in your
neighborhood where they got to leave for
good from this neighborhood now this
chaos brewing in that neighborhood oh
yeah Agatha's up to no good she's a
witch who likes to sing has a really
nice ring Joe will stay it through her
neighborhood today
wow that was great again these are all
songs that we'll be featured
um now again I unlike uh my other
esteemed panelists I neither have a
knowledge of Broadway oh uh musical
singing ability or knowledge of any song
that's been released since 2004. so uh
with those caveats uh this is gonna be a
big character reveal song
we know we've got some big castings uh
and this this is going to be that we'll
get three or four episodes deep in a
coven of chaos when this number kicks in
that finally reveals who this this
person has been cast as okay this is uh
little indie rock ditty from the early
90s
sent to the tune of Beck's Loser okay
yes while you visited the zoo I was a
monkey when you were at The Rock Show I
was a Punky at the bookstore I sold you
a journal you got some popcorn I ate all
your kernels oh it's insane to complain
about the faces I've been I was the ice
cream man served cold as Sin I cut you
off in traffic and zoomed down the
street you ordered a couch and I
delivered a love song don't believe
everything that you see I was a parking
attendant blowing boogies on my sleeve
rewind the tape and look for the
watermark I was there all along
lifeguard at the water park yo cut it
Sasha
there it is
Mephisto baby the Crown Prince of
Darkness
go baby the Crown Prince of Darkness
a true sequel to Gary Oldman
I mean that's a dorky song but it would
be great if like
had been like hiding in the background
of the first place or something like
that maybe shape shape shifting into
different characters
like that I love it all right Jessica
take us home
this is a great song it also said
Deborah Joe Rupp above it so I think
this is the song that she's gonna sing
oh she's the one that says stop it
stop it red red
are you ready yeah lucky lucky witch you
oh wait before I start can I point at
you I need you to go ding okay
lucky lucky witch you cause a scene and
then you dipped out like a [ __ ] you
kicked us out when the feds come through
about all the the ks magic that you do
dirty dirty tricks you know everyone is
cursing on the scene I hear them
Whispering about the visions that you've
seen and how you don't know how to
please your damn machine
Scarlett don't know Daddy's getting it
getting torn apart this is something
Unholy I'm sat back while you're
laughing at she be crying that we're
putting down Sparky
her kids are left another Zoe
so she can suck it Scarlett don't know
Daddy's getting it getting torn apart
this is something Unholy oh
wow well needless to say this Show's
probably gonna be canceled because we
stole all their music yeah
yeah oh made you look now let's talk
some super chess before we get out of
here you Super Rat yeah uh sir Zach the
Dodson was that a play on my name is
that it's not always about you I'm
self-centered I apologize saying y'all
are amazing um
I know this is film juice uh subterfuge
uh changing his name like that oh our
good friend's free girl hopping in there
uh what we call Din Mando daddy oh can
you read that Brandon I can't see it
around the camera Mando daddy Mandalore
by the end of the season we're gonna
call it Mando Danny Mandalore
if I could see it oh yeah oh he is going
to be a surrogate father Pedro Pascal on
the red carpet that was like yeah I'm
your [ __ ] daddy oh an angel
he's like a dog that's been sick for
days anything can come out of him
Noob Master also says is there a Quantum
realm in every Universe also contain
Direct Time alterations like strange did
with the time Stone I think we've
discussed that maybe the quantum realm
exists below every Universe it kind of
is like a little Cherry pit yeah I like
to imagine there's only one Quantum
realm but you can get into it through
all the other yeah so you can come 838
you can come 616. I mean I guess you
could you could theorize that because if
if every Universe has multiple timelines
and that's how they were doing the Time
Heist was zipping through the quantum
realm maybe all the timelines in one
Universe connected a Quantum realm and
every Universe has multiple timelines
and multiple Quantum and their own
Quantum realm I don't know okay but I
like to think there's just one yeah just
one maybe maybe they'll answer that in
quantumania um also oh sorry Zach go
ahead no I was just really quickly gonna
shut up Brandon happens to be wearing
two pieces of new rock stars yeah that's
right yes he's got the new Rockstar's
hoodie on and the twist of removing
company
so this shirt not currently available in
public but will be soon this is our
circles and arrows button up the pattern
is taken from our thumbnails of our
YouTube videos are we like point to
little missable details in the frame uh
this shirt is going to be available new
Rockstar's merch sometime soon you know
what we've been talking about like the
value of having kind of nerdy clothing
items that are kind of business casual
yeah you know what I mean you could wear
them to meet some in-laws or uh it's a
little business meeting and not feel uh
different about it you can wear a
graphic tee to those things too but I'm
gonna wear them to meet my sin-laws
those are my dominatrix's parents all
right now uh xenix also sent a chat and
said I'm in Northern Ireland but I'll
try anywhere to see Sir Thomas back
towards presence so yes definitely take
a trip to the UK for future coins oh
xenix
that's a pretty strong banshees
Adventure in uh kind of accent there uh
Northern Ireland's a lovely Place
Brandon's been there I've only been to
the Republic of Ireland but I want to
get to Northern Ireland sometime soon
xenix
I hope to be seeing you there soon and
perhaps we'll do a 23 and me and spit
into each other's mouths and see if
we're family I went to a Northern
Ireland I ate at a nandos
Velasquez hey friend of the show come on
the show I'm on the shower
uh okay I think you know what let's get
out of here
thank you so much for watching the show
today
um check out on the channel we've got
breakdown to the first episode of The
Last of Us breakdowns of the Mandalorian
trailer
um Tommy's got a fun Mandalorian video
coming out on the channel later this
week we've got some other fun Marvel
content coming out uh lots of good stuff
be sure come back Monday morning Sunday
night Sunday night thank you uh our
Monday break room shows uh for the next
eight weeks are going to be shifting to
Sunday night the last of us after shows
you can see Brandon Jessica and Anna
vanston will be on there reacting to
episode two of the last of us as soon as
that episode's over you can turn on new
rock stars and hear your buddies on the
break room talk about this no and let it
put it on autoplay let it run all night
while you see it yeah you know what I
mean you know they get those views no ad
blocker yeah really crank it I gotta run
slow speed uh
slow speed it'll weld them to sleep
I really
uh tomorrow's episode we gotta fill time
so we're gonna be doing the whole thing
we should do it we should do an episode
at 0.5 speed and then people play it
back at faster
sounds like we're praising yeah we're
always praising Satan yeah that's right
our Quaaludes episode uh hail Mephisto
no thank you thank you so much wait that
was only supposed to be one episode I've
been doing a Quaaludes episode for a
month
uh thank you so much for watching thank
you to everybody in the chat uh thank
you to our mods and uh thank you for our
mommy out there and our mom oh everybody
have a have a great uh rest of your day
thank you everybody bye
[Music]